[Music]
I had a lot of years to develop theonis
Creed in front of the camera so as a
director I had a Clear Vision of what I
wanted this story to be and where I
wanted to see the Creed family go action
Mike has done such an incredible job
directing this film I had an amazing
community of directors who were willing
to pass on knowledge to me you know
Denzel stepen cable Ryan cougler people
who you know done it once or twice great
job bro
Mike had a great understanding of story
and an ambition to him to see him
approaching the work in an almost
athletic way was just an honor to get to
watch great God J great God the fun part
was Finding ways to KI it to the next
[Music]
level the final scene of Creed 3 takes
place in a beautiful and Stark empty
Dodger Stadium after Adonis Creed has
won the heavyweight champ belt back you
know she's been waiting all night for
this
right she looks good in
there yeah that scene is the culmination
of a lot of relationships in the movie
and a lot of character Journeys know
right Donis has this intimate moment
with his family I'm better now the film
really is about this family and The
Godfather at all was the original Rocky
movie some 45 years ago and that last
scene in Creed 3 just brings it all
together in the scene alongside Adonis
Creed are Bianca Creed and his daughter
Amara Creed played by Tessa Thompson and
the incredible Mila Davis Ken Tessa
she's been here every step of the way
she brings a sense of care and comfort
to me personally these films obviously
are a lot about family and I think
what's been so beautiful to see for
Bianca is over the course of these films
her get to make her own
family MAA is just amazing she really
gives tremendous
authenticity and she has so much
Charisma that comes out in the scene
getting to work with Mila was so
life-changing ASL is an incredibly
beautiful language there's all sorts of
subtleties that I found so inspiring
it's very different shooting scene with
sign language in it you're not hearing
the dialogue and you're imagining what
the dialogue it's going to be you know
it from the script but you're not
directly interacting with it but you can
just sort of feel what they're saying
it's really all about capturing intimacy
with the actors and not getting in in
the way of it and having sort of
fluidity to it I think a lot of people
will feel inspired and happy about this
film and it shows the deaf experience
and what we go through so that people
really can understand our culture better
better we got to actually hang out and
spend some time with Mara and I and and
Mike too and just be together so I think
by the time that we were shooting there
was a real comfortability the
interesting thing about this scene is
that it was never the final scene in The
Script we had many drafts of the script
where it was a much more Ensemble Le
ending and when we were in the final
days of the Dodger Stadium set Michael
had this idea to potentially just end
the movie with the family alone in the
ring and it was truly Michael's Vision
that led us to this
moment there's so much emotion between
Adonis and Amara and that it did feel
like it could be wordless and the ASL
stuff was actually this huge Advantage
for us because it's such a emotive
expressive
language wow I think what's coming
through that last scene is the joy of
family I think Michael really wanted to
capture that aspect of the story and I
think he did it as well as could be done
boxing's always been about Fathers and
Sons and I wanted to explore what it was
like for fathers and daughters have
Amara also teach Adonis things make him
a better father a better husband was
something that we wanted to show there's
a very reflective
aspect to it this idea of overcoming
your own past and learning how to
forgive yourself is something that
Michael was very interested
in repeating the past is a fear of his
getting it right for Adonis this time
around means a lot to him especially as
a father looking back at how Apollo
played such a huge impact on his life he
wanted to make sure he was going to be
around for his family
no I think Adonis in this movie is in
this very transitional phase of it in
his life of trying to reconcile his
identity as a fighter and a celebrity
and a father beginning to realize that
you're passing on a torch we have a new
champ that he in this moment is stepping
into the role that was absent from his
life and Keenan and Zach we would often
talk about how time is short and
precious and not taking things for
granted Our intention was to have a
sense that there can be family life in
the world of boxing no one knows the
character of Adonis Creed better than
Michael B Jordan and the scene at the
end of the film was quite intricate he
had to convey all that Adonis has been
through not through one movie not
through two movies but through three
movies having it all culminate with his
family in the ring at the end of this
film and the results were
Magnificent the final scene of Creed 3
is the definition of a team effort
everything from the Beautiful words on
the page to Michael's Vision to the
cinematography to the production design
to the costume design to the acting to
the score it all beautifully fit
visually Michael really knew what he
wanted to do with this
scene there was a pivotal scene at the
end of the last crate at Apollo's grave
site and I used the colors and the
textures of that and sort of paralleled
that in this scene one of the motifs for
Donis Creed is the American flag Liz
wolf our incredible costume designer
came up with something that was very
very powerful I created a track suit
that sure it shows off his physique but
also he's shrouded in something that
almost feels
baptismal and for Bianca her spirit
animal between Tessa and myself has
always been a butterfly the butterfly in
significance of things like
transformation she feels like she's
hovering in love around the family and
she's standing behind the ropes watching
her daughter and her husband box and
then Amara is sort of a 50/50 split
between the two she's shadowing her
dad's pinstriped suits and definitely
trending on you know her mother's
enviable style she is the future of the
Creed Legacy KN out the pallet of the
Dodger Stadium fight and the finale
scene were quite intentional Michael
worked very closely with our amazing
director photography crer Morgan th and
our production designer jamine Assa to
maximize the space and the look and the
feel of Dodger Stadium that was
something that Kramer the
cinematographer did so amazingly where
you have this huge scale of something
but then it feels intimate the camera's
put in a specific place so you can catch
all those little
emotions out we shot this on a sound
stage in Georgia and we lit it as if the
environment was at Dodger Stadium
Imagining the visual effect background
that was going to be
there no there's a lot of help with
visual effect supervisor Jennifer mislan
making it feel like we're in an empty
Dodger Stadium and I don't think anybody
could really tell that this is shot in
the
[Music]
stage there's a huge amount of
infrastructure that goes into creating a
scene like this we built a lighting rig
into a Sound Stage that emulates all
these lights that are in the boxing ring
and in the stadium and we really just
shot this with two cameras but primarily
with one camera with a steady Cam that
just floats with the actors and tells a
story now we have a new champ the actors
were just so good and so
natural there very little dialogue in
this scene I think it's just beautiful
it's a family reuniting communicating
with one another in the way that they do
as a family
unit
the steady cam allowed us to really just
float with the actors the camera's
constantly moving and rapping and
building into the sort of Crescendo at
the end of the movie as the music
swelling we just kind of improvise this
pull back along the ropes and he
disappears in the darkness and you know
lo and behold that's the final shot of
the
movie
[Music]
film making is the medium where you need
and team you know so many other you know
moving pieces and parts that that come
together in order to shoot a film it's a
full team
sport wow it's a high bar obviously in a
47-year-old beloved franchise that is
famous for its endings we knew we had to
really come with an incredibly emotional
and impactful
ending when you see it all together with
the visual effects with the stadium in
the background it just has a
magnificence to it it was like a very
nice solution that we found towards the
end of the shooting process to realize
like it would be really nice to end this
movie in a bit kind of Silent emotional
way yeah sometimes there is no perfect
line perfect line is no line
[Music]
yeah